Karin is with us in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania hi Karen how are you hey
good Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay I hear what you
say about keeping up with others and
that people have this urge to want to
buy that you know to keep up with the
Joneses my problem is I don't care about
the Joneses I don't need their cars I
don't need their homes I've had plenty
of nice cars I've had plenty of nice
homes much of them are money pits anyway
but my problem is the opposite I worry
that people won't like me or look at me
as a decent person unless I have nice
things
and this I have I don't compare myself
to others but if somebody came in to my
house and thought oh your furniture
needs to be replaced or oh your hair you
need better highlights or where did you
get those clothes I feel like I'm
horrified that people won't like me
unless I have nice things so I kind of
have the opposite problem and it's it's
just it's um it's faulty some here
something's faulty what advice do you
have for that type of thinking hmm well
you know one of the benefits that I had
when Sharon and I went broke I was 28
we had babies toddler and a brand-new
baby Rachel was born that year
and I I was more shallow more like
you're talking about earlier not you but
like other where I was real concerned
about that you know if I get this car I
was getting stuff to show off you know I
was that shallow okay you know that kind
of guy right and so I but going through
that two and a half years of losing
everything and fighting with these
bankers and really having not only a
huge life experience but a spiritual
transformation during that time as well
my walk with God changed substantially I
used to laugh and say I met God on the
way up I got to know him on the way down
you know what I mean I mean when you go
through hell you just it changes you and
so what ended up happening was I went
from a person who cared very much what
everyone thinks
to a person who doesn't care at all
I mean I like waiting cause anyway hear
you say that stresses me out that you
don't care at all how do you not care at
all I mean how I I just you're speaking
great when you say that because I just
don't I just don't connect with that
that's my that's what I thought you were
saying so that's why I told you a story
but then I'm spending too much to have
things just that people think I'm
adequate yeah
and and here's the thing it's peep
people think you adequate it's someone
that you care what their opinion is and
so what we all have is we all have this
concentric circles in our lives like if
you drop a petal in the water the
circles going out like a target okay the
ones in the closest rings to us are the
ones we care what they think the most
the ones way in the distance we care
less what they think or we should in
other words your closest family members
the people who love you they're
concerned about you they're concerned
about your future they should have the
most influence with you your closest
friends the people that are you know if
some stranger at a stoplight rolls their
eyes about your car
who gives a rip they're in one of those
way outer rings you know what I'm saying
and so I think you need to start
establishing that clearly and say whose
condemnation is it that I'm really
fearing here and if it's someone inside
those closed circles then is that a
toxic relationship for instance maybe
I'll just make up something okay let's
pretend there was a person like you
whose mother was very shallow and very
vocal and judged you based on they roll
their eyes and rolling your eyes as a
sign of contempt it is one of the worst
things you can do to anyone it's one of
the most disrespectful things and so
kind of what you're saying is I'm afraid
people are rolling their eyes about my
couch or about my clothes okay yeah and
you know if it's a stranger who gives a
rip right but if it's somebody up close
to me and they have I have a toxic
relationship with them meaning that like
instance if your mother was really
shallow and she came in and she's like
well you're nobody and that you know she
puts you down that's somebody's real
close to you and that really hurts even
though they're toxic and even though
they're completely inappropriate that
hurts so you need to establish do I have
healthy relationship do I have
relationships with healthy people in my
closest circles and I'm guessing you
don't all right I'm guessing someone
inside your closest circle is not a
healthy person and it's putting this
crap on you
it's a pebble in my shoe yeah is what it
is yeah and you know that you already
saw their face while we were talking
didn't you yeah I did and so what it is
you just have a look at them and go well
you can act like you were from the south
if you were from the south you'd look at
them and you'd say bless your heart
[Laughter]
which kind of means jump off a cliff
right I love that I know I love that but
I mean I could go bankrupt I could spend
all my money doing trying to trying to
make that person happy about what you
own which is really weird if you think
about it I'm gonna make them happy about
what I own well when you put it like
that it does sound rather backwards that
is you know and it's like that you know
like I've got a really nice car I drove
down here today from my house but I
don't drive that car because of what
anybody else says though it thinks I
Drive it because I really like the car
because after what I went through I'm
not really motivated by other people I
don't I mean what the Bible calls fear
of man and yet there's people they call
there's starving children are dying
because Dave Ramsey bought this nice car
you know and and you know what if that's
you and you're out there listening
you're just a nut and I don't really
care what you think and so I'm still
gonna drive my car and you just got to
get to the point that the people that
are closest to you if you have health if
they're healthy yeah I want them to have
influence in my life but to the extent
that they're unhealthy I don't and I
think that's what you've got here and
it's anytime someone's judging you for
what you don't have or for what you do
have
they need to learn to mind their own
business and they are being toxic so
it's a great book called boundaries that
I think will help you with this it's a
great discussion I don't know that I've
ever had a question posed quite like
that
so it's a really interesting way of
looking at it and most of the time it's
the other way it's like you know
everybody should go be successful but
once you're successful then everybody
hates you because rich people are all
evil you know and that's usually the you
know we talk about that a lot it's
called Gnosticism in the spiritual realm
which is a form of heresy it says that
if you have nice things that if you have
if you've been successful and you've
acquired some nice things that
automatically that means you're a bad
person automatically that means you're
not spiritual automatically that means
dot dot dot negative thing and so that's
kind of like a warped toxic form of
Christianity it's called heresy I talked
about that in the book of the legacy
journey so I'm going to send you a copy
of the legacy journey I'm also going to
send you a copy of boundaries read both
of them because you're really wrestling
with this in a good way Karen it's good
to wrestle with these theological and
philosophical questions they make us who
we are and I like doing it on the air
with you sometimes it's cool this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]